una ciudad al norte de ankara conocida
por haber albergado al legendario héroe
bardo core o club una especie de robin
hood del mundo turco pero voló ahora es
noticia en turquía por una razón muy
distinta la ciudad se ha convertido en
el símbolo de la ola de discriminación
anti árabe que se extiende por el país
solo cada vez que pasa algo en síria
salió con que habrá problemas aquí
pse y pnv es originario de irak llegó a
bolo hace 7 años prefiere mantener el
anonimato aquí nos establecen una
diferencia no importa que sea sirio o
iraquí da igual hace unos meses mataron
a unos soldados turcos en siria entonces
ellos atacaron a todos los árabes no
decían devuelvan se devuelvan y luchen
porque debemos ser nosotros los que
morimos en su país pero honestamente yo
qué culpa tengo
safe huyo de la guerra pero dice que
ahora enfrenta a otro tipo de violencia
la guerra psicológica es aún peor que la
guerra de verdad cuando trabajamos nos
miran como si fuéramos privilegiados
personas muy adineradas como si les
estuviéramos robando su empleo nos
reprochan todo es una guerra más dura
que la que se hace con armas de verdad
tanto a la alcaldía como la gobernación
son dirigidas por el chp el partido
kemalista la mayor organización política
de la oposición turca según unas medidas
locales actualmente suspendidas por ser
demasiado controversiales los
extranjeros debían asumir el costo de
facturas de agua y energía con tarifas
aumentadas un matrimonio en el hotel de
la ciudad debía costar les cien veces
más que a los turcos y además debían
obedecer a un toque de queda después de
las nueve de la noche
tratamos de contactar al alcalde tan
jugó tan pero su equipo nos indicó que
no deseaba expresarse en la prensa
extranjera aquí está en un programa de
la televisión turca
70 por ciento de los extranjeros en bolo
son iraquíes
hay una guerra en irak nuestros
empresarios crean empleos y capital en
irak en bagdad en ebril el sistema que
permitió invitarlos ya cumplió su tiempo
debemos asegurar que se devuelva porque
las cifras siguen aumentando como
pretende usted integrar un afgano los
cercanos acosan a nuestros jóvenes de 15
años y ni siquiera se dan cuenta porque
en su país se casan con niñas de 9 años
como pretende usted integrar a esas
personas
turquía acoge más refugiados que
cualquier otro país del mundo tres
millones setecientos mil sirios
trescientos treinta mil iraquíes
hombres mujeres y niños que no pueden
regresar a sus países de origen incluso
aunque técnicamente no sean considerados
como refugiados por la ley turca tienen
un estatus de invitados una
particularidad jurídica que ya no parece
ser adecuada
si no hay una verdadera política un
verdadero plan de integración en turquía
ese es el problema y no hay
transparencia sobre la política
migratoria
y la sunat aaa es especialista en
políticas migratorias de la universidad
de estambul según ella los refugiados
solían ser bienvenidos pero los actos
xenofóbicos surgieron cuando los turcos
entendieron que los inmigrantes habían
llegado para quedarse
para solucionar el tema de los
refugiados hay que empezar por
ofrecerles una protección
a esas poblaciones refugiadas deberían
convertirse en miembros de la sociedad
porque no hay oportunidades no pueden
regresar
sigue habiendo conflictos sin embargo
hoy en día nos damos cuenta de que todo
eso ya no está funcionando
d y
la degradación de la situación económica
empeora el panorama los extranjeros son
acusados de ser responsables del aumento
en los precios de los inmuebles de la
disminución de los salarios incluso de
quitarle el empleo a los turcos pero lo
que más le preocupa a este foro donde se
reúnen grupos de defensa por los
derechos de los refugiados es la
banalización de la xenofobia en el
discurso público
ahora que turquía se acerca a las
elecciones cada vez hay más discursos
discriminatorios en los medios o por
parte de algunos políticos
baja el gas y es un sitio que trabaja
para el ministerio turco de educación
también es activista y se reúne con
dirigentes políticos turcos para tratar
de convencerlos de que no aprovechen el
clima actual por razones electorales
[Música]
todos los partidos deberían firmar una
declaración común un texto para asegurar
que el tema de los refugiados sirios
esté excluido de sus programas
en realidad todas las versiones tienen
su cuota de responsabilidad
tanto el gobierno como la oposición es
responsabilidad de todos poner fin a los
discursos de odio porque estos discursos
no sólo son una amenaza para la
comunidad siria sino también para el
conjunto de la comunidad turca
el pasado 12 de agosto cientos de
personas atacaron comercios y viviendas
en este barrio de ankara después de que
dos sirios fueran acusados de haber
causado la muerte de un adolescente
turco el estado turco enfrenta una
contradicción aunque sigue recibiendo
dinero de la unión europea para mantener
a los migrantes en su territorio una
parte cada vez mayor de la población ya
no quiere acogerlos